네. 안녕하세요. 오늘 어 빌사남이
간다 드라이브스루로 편을 또
준비했는데 어 삼성동 편을 좀 준비를
했습니다. 가볍게 어 저랑 삼성동을
좀 돌아보면서 어 최근에 뭐 투자
사례라든지 그리고 뭐 삼성동에 좀
어떤 지역에도 사람들이 투자를 좀
많이 하는지 저와 한번 어 직접
보시면서 이야기를 나눠 보도록
하겠습니다. 어 일단은 지금 좌측이
이제 삼성동인데 지금 강남구청역에서
이제 선정력 쪽 블록을 볼 거예요.
그래서 여기는 대체적으로 좀 이제
아파트 단지가 좀 많이 밀집되어 있고
여기에 뭔가 상권이 있거나 그러진
않는 거 같아요. 그래서 대부분 다
그냥 이제 주거 시설이랑 어 역
근처에는 이제 오피스가 많이 밀집되어
있고 어 일단은 지금 뭐 주택에 대한
규제도 워낙 심하고 물론 이제 시간이
굉장히 좀 오래됐지만 주거 관련해서
이제 사업을 한다라고 하면은
정책적이라든지 뭔 그런 이슈들을 좀
많이 받는 거 같습니다. 그래서
여기서 이제 좌회전을 해서 선정력
쪽으로가 볼 예정이에요. 그래서
여기도 사실 삼성동이긴 하지만 지금
뭐 GBC 개발하는거나 그런 삼성
역에 영향을 받을 사실 그런 위치는
아니에요. 같은 삼성동이긴 하지만 어
거기랑도 거리가 되게 멀고 GBC
영향을 많이 받아 가지고 여기 뭐
빌딩 거래도 많이 될 거다. 뭐 이런
얘기를 하는데 사실 제가 봤을 때
이쪽 물러까지는 뭐 영향이 크게 있을
것 같진 않습니다. 물론 뭐 관련된
업체들이 오피스로 들어올 수 있겠죠.
근데 여기에 뭐 갑자기 뭐 별도의
상건이 생기거나 그럴 거 같진
않아요.
>> 오늘은 어떻게 그러면은 루트를 좀
계획을 하셨는
>> 그래서 일단 강남구청역에서
선정 능력 쪽까지 가서 좀 가볍게
살짝 보고 그다음에 이제 선능 공원
쪽 본 다음에 삼성역 쪽으로 넘어가서
그 맨 마지막엔 이제 그 코엑 앞에서
마무리할 예정입니다. 그리고 여기
보면은 여기 보건소 얼마 전에
왔었죠. 엔터 설립하러 갔었는데요
앞에 보면은 그 고급 이런 하이엔드
오피스텔들이 되게 많아요. 근데 이제
뭐 지금 여기뿐만 아니라 도산대로에
있는 하이엔드 오피스텔도 지금 공실이
되게 많습니다. 네. 몽실도 되게
많고 예를 들어서 실제 그때 당시에는
막 월세 700만 원 막 이렇게
광고를 했는데 실제로 맞춰진 거는 막
300만 원 이렇게 반토막 나왔어요.
그래서 그때 정말 말도 안 되게 비싼
가격에 뭐 분양도 했었고 임대 광고도
했었고 근데 실질적으로는 지금 오히려
마이너스 붙어 있고 그리고 임대가 안
되고 있는 지금 상황입니다. 그다음에
여기가 이제 선정 능력 쪽이고 여기
선정 능력 쪽은 뭐 특별한 뭐
상권이나 이런게 없어요. 그냥 대부분
다 이제 그냥 오피스 있는 정도.
저는 개인적으로 여기 블록보다는 저기
선능 공원 있는 블록이 되게 괜찮은
거 같아요. 저 예전에 빌사남도
저쪽에 있었지만 점심 시간 때 이쪽
선능공원 좀 많이 걸어다녔었거든요.
그래서 오피스를 사용하 있어서 되게
큰 메리트가 있는 거 같습니다.
강남에 이렇게 큰 자연을 볼 수 있는
이런 공원이 없는 거 같아요.이
정도로 큰 사이즈에. 그래서 안에
실제로 들어가 보시면 와 강남구에
어떻게 이런 곳이 있다고라고 할
정도로 굉장히 크고 정말 경주에서 볼
법한 어 그런 정이 있습니다. 그래서
여기 이제 자측에 들어갈 겁니다.
>> 내비로 갔을 때 크기가 상당하네.
>> 엄청 커요. 거의 한 블록을 다 있을
정도. 어떻게 보면 여기 오피스에
있는 분들이 건강한 이유가요 선능
공원 때문입니다. 점심들 맨날
걸어다녀 가지고. 근데 상권적으로
봤을 때 이게 좋은 구조인가요?
>> 사실 이것 때문에 좀 막히긴 하지만
아, 중계도 하고 리모델링 한 다음에
인대 맞춘게 있거든요. 통임대로.
요즘에 뭐 통임대가 워낙 안 되긴
하는데 요것도 이제 지나가면서 보여
드릴게요. 선능 공원이 되게 잘
보입니다. 그래서 원래는 옆에 좁은
도로에 있는 건물을 한 60억 정도에
샀어요. 싸게 상업지를. 그러고 나서
옆에 있는 코너까지 같이 작업해서
올린 사례인데 일단은 저기 저희가 어
선능 공원이 잘 보이는 건물 통임대
마친 사례를 보여 드리겠습니다.
>> 근데 이거 안에서 통임대는 진짜
>> 직전 저거 보이시죠?
>> 아 붉은 벽돌 건물인가요? 예, 예,
맞습니다. 요거를 저희가 중계하고
나서 통임대를 맞췄어요. 그래서 저기
이제 상부층 올라가면은 뷰가 되게 잘
보여요. 전능공원뷰 비가. 예.
그래서 지금 임대차 계약한지는 그렇게
오래 안 됐고 지금 이제 인테리어
공사 들어가려고 하고 있습니다. 이게
뭔가 강남에서 이런 느낌이 없습니다.
지금
>> 자연적으로 뭔가 와닿는 느낌이
들어요.
>> 그니까 그리고 요게 이승철 씨
건물이잖아요. 이승철 씨가 예전에
경매로 낙찰 받아 가지고 엔터테인먼트
들어가겠구나.
LSC
그죠? 뭐 너무 잘 받았죠?
>> 매너선인가요?
>> 예. 항상 매너는 중요합니다. 매너가
사람을 만듭니다. 아, 우리 저
예전에 중계했던 거 그 마일스톤
사례도 한번 좀 설명드릴게요. 그것도
이제 40억 원에 사 가지고 리모델링
한 다음에 최근에 80억 초반에
매각을 했어요. 그래서 그것도 뭐
상가 주택 있던 되게 낡은
건물이었는데 리모델링 되게 잘해
가지고 매각한 사례입니다. 근데 사실
뭐 리모델링 비용이랑 이런 거
세금이랑 이런 거 따지면은 뭐 두
배까진 아닐 거 같아요. 뭐 그래도
한 30억 좀 안 되게 되지 않나
싶기는 한데 아 저기 칸스 아세요
저기
>> 아 저기 네
>> 저기 막 명품 중고 같은 거 팔잖아요
예 맞
>> 아 여기 진짜 공실이 많아요.
봉원사로가 공실이 많습니다. 이게
원래 뭐 사람 다니는 길은 아닌데
요전에 그 한방병어 있었는데 원장님이
돈 가지고 요. 아 이건 넣어도
되나?
이거 마일스톤 요겁니다. 요거 예전에
되게 낡은 상가 주택이었어요. 우리
유튜브 보면 아실 거예요. 그래서
요것도 매각을 했습니다. 80억
초반에로 쭉 들어가서요 안에도 공실이
되게 많아요.
>> 진짜 어려운 구간이네요. 공실이
많다는 거는 사실
>> 그죠 뭐 근데 여기뿐만 아니라 여기
안에 뭐 상권도 없고 주거랑 오피스만
밀집되어 있습니다. 그래서 뭐
삼성동에서 그나마 상권 있는 데가
이제 그 코스 맞은 편. 거기는
비싸죠. 여기는 지금 포스코 사거리
쪽이네요.
>> 와 이렇게만 보면 약간 뉴욕에 있는
이런 조각상 같은 느낌인데
>> 살짝 월스트레스에서 많이 본 것 같은
느낌.
>> 여기가 이제 삼성6 가고 있고 그다음
여기 오른쪽에 보면은 그 빗썸에서
이제 건물 지으려고 하고 있죠. 여기
좀만 더 가면 그래서 지금 빗썸이랑
저기 두나무가 샀는데 저는 개인적으로
땅의 가치로만 봤을 때는 빗썸이 더
괜찮아요. 그래서 빗썸은 완전
상업지고 두나무가 샀던 건 이제 노선
상업지 상업지랑
이제 삼종이랑 같이 있는 어 그런
땅이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 땅의 가치로는 빗썸이 더
괜찮은 거 같고 그래서 지금 약간 그
무슨 각물식으로 좀 만들어 놨어요.
그래서 지금 뭐 아마 설계하는데
시간이 좀 오래 걸릴 거예요. 그래도
뭐 한 1, 2년 걸릴 거 같은데또
설계하고 있는 동안은 낮은 단층
건물로 만들어 가지고 이제 홍보
목적으로 좀 하고 있는 거 같습니다.
그래서 두 업체 다 대출을 안
받았어요. 거의 한 약 한 3,억
정도에 웨입을 했습니다. 그래서 저는
강남구에서 뭐 전에 영상에도
말씀드렸지만 제일 개발호재가 많은
데는 삼성역이라고 생각하고 정말 천지
개벽을 할 곳이라고 생각합니다.
앞으로 더 많은 사람들이 몰릴 거고
지금지기 공사하고 있는 것도 보이지만
지하를 거의 한 뭐 6층까지 파
가지고 지금 파이 있거든요. 제가 뭐
들어가서 정확히 볼 순 없지만 지금
거의 파져 있습니다. 네. 그다음에
여기 보면은 빗썸 있고요.
>> 구조물이 되게 특이하네요. 과물이라는
거죠.
>> 이거를 3,억 주고 샀어요. 이렇게
두 개. 그래서 뭐든지 좀 좋은 이런
투자 상품은 잘 가지고 있는게 지키는
것도 방법인 거 같습니다.
>> 앞으로 우리나라도 베네수엘라처럼
비트코인을 화폐로
여길까요? 베르네스라가는 엘살바도로
하
>> 엘살바도로 제못
>> 뭐 법정 앞에 이런 건 안 되겠지만
근데 저는 앞으로 봤을 때 비트코인
안에 테더로 거래하는 날도 얼마 안
남았다 생각합니다. 네시고
엄청 큽니다 이거 지금 내가 이거 참
할 말이 많은데 하지 않겠습니다.
여기 이제 봉운 사역 사거리에 와
있습니다. 여기 보면은 진짜 전강판들
되게 화려하죠. 이제 여기 관광객들도
지금 사진 찍고 있고. 여기 앞에
있는게 제일 화려해요. 어, 지금 막
무슨 뭐 타임스퀘어처럼. 그리고
삼성동에서 제일 좋은 데가 어디야라고
하면은 일단 저 GBC 있는
블록이에요. 예. 거기가 아무래도
GBC 지어지면 바로 영향을 받기
때문에 거기가 제일 비싸고. GBC가
일단 평당 4억에 샀어요.
2014년도에. 그때 당시 진짜 말도
안 된다. 너무 비싸게 샀다. 뭐
얘기가 되게 많은데 지금 돌이켜
생각해 보면 또 그때보다 가격이 많이
올랐죠. 그다음에 어찌 됐든이 삼성력
인근은 굉장히 괜찮아요. 근데 여기
상권도 참 아이러니한 거는 주말엔
사람이 없습니다. 주말에는 일단은
코엑스에 지하로 다녀요. 예. 지하로
유동인 거 다 많아서 여기 건너편에
사람이 그렇게 많지 않습니다. 그리고
이쪽으로 쭉 가다 보면 흑동가가
있어요. 네. 던가는 그 전지현 씨가
매입을 했습니다. 그래서 그때 당시에
거의 300억이 넘는 돈을 대출 없이
사 가지고 아직까지 가지고 있고
그때와 비슷하게 또 건물 샀던 사람이
대성이 도산대로의 건물을 샀었거든요.
300억대. 근데 지금 오랜 시간이
지났지만 가격이 옳은 측면을 봤을
때는 대성 건물이 건물이 가격이 더
많이 올랐습니다. 일단은 용도 지역
자체가 좋아요. 더. 그래서 노선
상업지 이제 상업지도 같이 끼고 있어
가지고 지금도 건물이 되게 높지만 어
더 올릴 여지도 있던 건물입니다.
네. 물론 이제 뭐 여기 혁동과
전지현 씨 건물도 오르긴 했지만데 뭐
그때 당시에 뭐 여기 대로변인데 뭐
1억 정도에 샀었으니까 그래서 뭐
그래도 잘 샀죠. 그래서 여기 보면은
이렇게 기본적으로 상권이 좀 있긴
해요. 지금 점심 시간때데 저녁에도또
유동인 거 좀 있는 곳입니다. 그
오피스 건물 때문에 보면은 다 저기서
오르잖아요. 밥 먹으려고. 그래서
이게 대로변에 오피스가 있는게 되게
매력적이에요. 이렇게 큰 오피스들이
있는게 여기는 그냥 노선 상업지도
아니고 다 상업지거든요. 그래서
건물이 다 높아 가지고 오피스 유동인
거가 되게 많아요. 저 예전에 투썸
경매 나왔었는데 200 200억 좀
넘게 나왔는데 저 그냥 취화됐어요.
제가 들어가고 싶었는데 그리고 저기가
이제 삼종이긴 하지만 용종률도 꽉
채워서 지었고 초과됐었나 아무튼
그랬던 거 같은데 제가 제일 좋아하는
스타일의 건물인데 데로벤 코너 아니
진짜 저기 D비 손내본 저 건물만
지금 되게 높아요 그죠는 건물 중에
저게 인센티브 받아 가지고 거의
1,000% 넘을 거야 아마 저 뭐야
여러분들 내가 진짜 난 주차의 최고
난이도를 한번 경험해 보고 싶다라고
하시는 한번 저기저기 보이시죠?
샹제리제 센터 저기 한번 들어가
보시면 깜짝 놀래실 겁니다. 대로변에
희한하게 돼 있어요. 요거 요거 요거
보이시죠?
>> 검정색 건물이
>> 예. 요거 이제 저희가 중계했던 거고
원래는 그 옆에 작은 건물 있었는데
그걸 먼저 중계한 다음에요 코너
건물까지 같이 중계를 했어요.
그리고요 임차인 어떻게 구하는지
아세요?
>> 어떻게 구어?
>> 인스타그램 DM에서 구했습니다.
>> 와 그게 가능한가요?
>> 예하죠. 뭐 요즘 뭐 SNS 시대인데
원래는 두 건물 다 한 5층짜리
건물이었는데 요걸 이제 멸실한 다음에
저렇게 거의 뭐 20층 가까이
지었습니다. 건물을 그래서 두 개
땅을 매입하는데 한 190억이 정도에
샀거든요. 상업지다 보니까 저렇게
토지 활용도가 되게 높은 겁니다.
연면적은 거의 1,000평 가까이
되고 원래 이제 이종이지였으면은 뭐
한 2, 300평 3 정도 그 정도
수준인데 상업지다 보니까 이게 땅의
활용도가 되게 좋은 거 그래서 저런
식으로 이면의 걸 샀다가 이제 옆에
코너 거를 살 수도 있고 아니면
반대로 코너 땅을 샀다가 그 옆에
땅도 같이 이제 묶어서 지을 수도
있고 그래서 그런 전략들을 짜면 좋을
것 같습니다. 어 일단 삼성동도
가볍게 돌아봤는데 어떠셨나요? 네.
그래서 저도 이제 예전에 오피스
쓰면서 되게 정들었던 동네고 여기도
이제 저희가 실제로 뭐 개발하거나
아니면 이제 좀 이렇게 중계했던
건물들이 되게 많은 곳인데 올 때마다
어찌 됐든 좀 많이 변화하고 있고
강남구 내에서 제일 주목받는 동네인
거는 확실합니다. 네. 그래서
여러분들도 빌딩 투자하신다라고 하면은
어 삼성동에 좀 관심을 갖고 삼성동이
좀 어떻게 변화할지 그리고 특히
GBC 주변으로 좀 어떻게 변화할지를
계속 좀 지켜보시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요. 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다. 저는 밥 먹으러
가겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]